foreign
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi thank you for
trying to call sure what's up
um I was just wondering if we should pay
our mortgage or if we should wait until
we have a little bit more save
um that's like a safety net
okay do you have any other debt
no you're fairly new to this whole
Ramsay stuff aren't you
yes okay so we teach a process called
the baby steps
and it's how to apply it's the next step
the next thing and then the next thing
and the next thing a clear path from
where you are now to wealth first things
get a thousand dollars second thing is
be debt free but the house you've done
those two right
yes okay then the third step is to have
a fully funded emergency fund grandma
called it a rainy day fund the proper
amount is three to six months of
household expenses what's your household
income
um well I just quit my job so now it's
going to be about a hundred thousand
okay are you going back to work
no I'm going to be a stay-at-home mom
for a while okay how much is your house
payment
about 6 50
. good work Hannah wow okay that's weird
that's wonderfully weird okay and so um
okay so let's pretend that your monthly
expenses if everybody's income stopped
uh that you could live easily on uh four
thousand dollars a month I wouldn't be
far from wrong would I
no okay three times four is twelve
six times four is twenty four so you
should have an emergency fund of 12 to
24 000 before you start paying off your
house how much do you have in savings
95 000. okay let's allocate 20 000 of
that to your emergency fund now
everything else is going towards your
mortgage
how much is your mortgage balance
um about 92 000. Great okay so you said
you have ninety five thousand in savings
yes
okay
um well the the way we would teach it is
you keep your emergency fund of three to
six months we could call that 15 for fun
that'd be putting 80
on the house
and uh then you pay off the house what
by Christmas
if you only have 15 owed right and then
if you want to build up your emergency
fund a little further you could that's
what we would do around here because no
house payment is going to make you even
more brilliant than you already are and
you're Pretty stinking brilliant good
grief I love that that was like a slow
flex and we have a 95 000 and 600 house
payment
translation Hannah you are well on your
way before you ever met anybody called
Ramsey but we'll help you get it get
there even faster so Dave one of the one
of the criticisms I get is this this
situation
how do you tell somebody like because
mathematically that's it kind of went in
the lottery the 650 house payment
there's but there's the the umbrella the
shadow that sits over you that says
somebody else you owe money to right you
owe money to somebody else
how would you explain that to somebody
that says no it's worth it to go ahead
and do it
it's worth it to go ahead and pay that
thing off even though your house payment
is so low relative to what you're
bringing home every month
because
several things happen in addition to the
math being freed up
the first thing number one the math is
freed up and now you can invest and save
um and and be generous with your entire
income and it will cause you to be
wealthy faster that's the basic thing
but it's only 600 bucks for freeing up
here so it's not like it's a ton but
it's there and whatever else extra they
were paying or putting into savings so
she's got this vague savings over here
that hasn't got a real assignment yet it
doesn't have a mission the second thing
that happens is
um that people that don't have a single
piece of debt you talk about this they
relax in a place they didn't know was
tight
their relationships get better their
employment changes for the better
because they don't have to work there
they're uh the qual their health
improves literally I mean the
hypertension that we've faced in this
culture yeah people with mortgages don't
have as much high blood pressure hello
wow just think about it people that
don't have mortgages have peace
Financial Peace two words that don't go
together like Airline service